I'm Rafe Levine I'm on the Android UI
toolkit team and I'm gonna talk to you
today about Android textual layout and I
hope you'll find this an interesting
talk and I hope you brought lots of
questions as well and I'm happy to
address those after the session and also
an app at office hours this afternoon so
I'm going to talk about it it's kind of
a grab-bag of a bunch of different
topics around text and typography on
Android I'm going to talk about some of
the challenges and opportunities just a
little bit of an introduction to
material design which I'm sure everybody
here is quite familiar with then I'm
going to go into some of the details
about the Roboto 2 and Noto fonts and
especially the kind of more recent
changes around these to better support
international typography a huge amount
of the work that we do on the Android UI
toolkit team is is supporting all of the
languages of the world or or most of
them then I'm going to go into some of
the really I think exciting newer
features around open type typography
control and high-quality paragraph
layout which rolled out in lollipop and
marshmallow so so what are some of the
challenges and opportunities I mean I
come from a print background and mobile
doing typography on mobile is extremely
different than doing typography on print
there are some things in common but
there are some things that are that are
really different you have to be very
focused on the performance you know of
of the text stack because you've got
only so much battery and only so much
RAM but you really do have very powerful
compute resources you've got you know
multi-core multi gigahertz processes in
there so if you want to do sophisticated
advanced typography you do have the
compute power to do that 60 frames a
second is absolutely a requirement and
this is again both a challenge and an
opportunity that that you can do these
really rich animations and transitions
and do this kind of interactive motion
typography that that really is you know
completely impossible in a print
background but you
have to make everything fit in that
16-millisecond budget you've got a very
small screen and this has some
interesting challenges in how you create
your layouts how you do the paragraph
layout but but a flip side it again is
that on modern devices you have this
very high resolution then as I mentioned
you know we have this requirement to
support all of the languages of the
world all the scripts of the world but
we have a lot of really good resources
both in fonts and typography control of
how you do that and then you know I'm
gonna talk about some of the line
breaking improvements some of the
paragraph layout improvements in
marshmallow and those were really
motivated by a need to get this working
in very small screens like watch faces
so I'm gonna just kind of introduce this
concept of you know like the advance of
display technology this was the first
mobile device I ever had when I was 12
years old and I mean as you can see it's
got a lot of the elements of a modern
mobile device you know it even has a
really nice big keyboard but the display
technology at in this generation of
technology is kind of the bare minimum
that you need to get text displayed at
all and I think that that evolution you
know kind of carried that there was a
very primitive approach to just get the
the letters drawn on the screen and not
really think about typography another
good thing about the screenshot is you
get some sense of like the difference in
computing power available today as you
know back then so you know before I work
on Android I was working on Google web
fonts google fonts and the upper left
corner is kind of your classic laptop or
desktop screen and this really ruled
what we did that you have a very small
number of pixels to represent the text
and you have a lot of constraints and
how this letterforms map into those
pixels and that also includes like the
spacing you see kind of very poor like
the ANP or crunched up together and the
piano are separated because you only
have so many pixels in so much precision
but as you go into more modern display
technology you have so many more picks
and so on the upper right you have a 4k
monitor which is starting to replace
laptops and on the lower left this isn't
even the most recent device this is a
two year old device and it has 468 PPI
and you probably can't even see the
pixels here and then comparing that to
for example an inkjet printer you
actually have on these mobile devices
you have a much higher precision higher
quality representation of the shapes of
the letter forms and the spaces between
them so it really enables typography and
all of all four of these screenshots or
captures are the same 12-point Times
Roman and so this is what we have to
work with today this is our lead device
the Nexus 6p it's an amazing device and
it has an amazing screen to match match
the overall device it's at 515 PPI when
one of the ways I think about screen
resolution is you know when when Star
Trek you know when they were doing the
Star Trek TV show they had like a book
that had all of the specifications for
all the technology like how many
terajoules were in a phaser pulse and
one of the specifications is what is
discrete what is the resolution of these
little devices that people are carrying
around and the answer is 400 dpi
so you know we've blown way past Star
Trek so I mean as I say everybody here
knows about material design this this
will just touch on it that you know the
the UX team and started really about two
years ago that they were looking at
these kind of more powerful devices
higher quality display technologies and
they were really thinking how how if we
were redesigning this from scratch if we
really could do anything what would we
do and the result of that exploration
really synthesized into a set of
guidelines into a coherent design
language that incorporates many
different elements it incorporates you
know colors it incorporates the material
metaphors with paper and and kind of a
three-dimensional effect and it also
incorporates typography and so you know
one of the section
in the material design spec I really
recommend it's it's very you know has a
lot of good good information and a lot
of good guidance about how to do
typography within material design and of
course another part of that is a much
greater expanded palette of different
weights and of different sizes and how
you kind of use the weight in size
instead of having just one size of tax
one way you use this to indicate the
structure of your app the structure of
the information in your app so the the
cornerstone of typography in material
design is the Roboto 2 typeface and so
this was an update that happened in
lollipop and you know it was pretty
subtle a lot of people probably didn't
even notice it but there was actually a
lot going on in this update so one of
the things is the expanded Unicode
coverage it actually increased by a
factor of three and we have full support
for Unicode eight for Latin Greek and
Cyrillic scripts and that covers a lot
of the languages in the world that um
you know that are maybe less familiar to
us like the African languages use a lot
of kind of unusual Latin characters we
also expanded the weights and styles
that we ship on the device so we're
doing thin light regular medium bold and
black so there's a tremendous palette of
the visual effects that you can get and
all of those include true italics and we
also have a family of condensed which is
better for better information density
and also can give you some contrast you
know two different styles that you can
that you can work with in your app in
addition the Roboto 2 font is completely
open-source and that includes not just
the final TrueType font files but the
entire bill chain so you can go in there
and customize it and play with it and
and send us full requests and you know
we really treat almost everything we do
in a very open open-source manner so the
design updated as well
and this is just a little bit of a kind
of a before-and-after and you can see
there's it's it's a little subtle but
like there's kind
stiff sides to some of the characters
like a capital o and that has become a
more refined gentle curve some of the
shapes were maybe a little bit unusual
like the K's and the capital R and those
have become kind of more simplified and
more streamlined and we also went from a
square dot on the i's and J's to a round
on so it's just it's an evolution it's a
more refined form of the original kind
of you know design it's very central to
to Android and very central of course to
material design so you know I talked
about the global reach of the Android we
talked about a lot about the next
billion users and you know they're
they're like we heard in the previous
you know talk about you know how do you
reach them through the Play Store a
console but there's also a lot that you
have to do with the presentation of text
and language in these devices so again
Roboto to dramatically increases the
Unicode coverage and you can see this is
just a sample this is just one of the
pages of kind of additional extended
Latin characters and another thing I'll
point out just you know for this slide
summit like if you look kind of near the
middle on towards the left-hand side you
see some O's with some EE stacked
accents and that's a very common pattern
in a lot of languages but not not
European languages that we're used to so
you see it in Vietnamese and some of
these other languages so you really when
you're when you're designing your apps
when you're testing your apps you really
need to be careful to test them in some
of these other languages to make sure
that you've got enough vertical space
this is kind of one of the one of the
real key takeaways that if you just
design in English you've got these
letters they don't have anything going
on above they don't have anything going
on below but that is not the experience
of you know the millions hundreds of
millions of people around the world so
in addition to Latin Greek and Cyrillic
there's this huge diversity of other
languages and in fact this is the list
of scripts not even languages there's
many scripts that support multiple
languages
these are the no tow scripts that we're
supporting in marshmallow so it really
is you know huge expansion compared with
previous versions of Android and it
really covers a very large fraction of
the languages that are spoken in the
world and so here three scripts that I
just kind of picked out you know is
representative I you know I find I find
these just really beautiful and you can
see you know kind of a tension between
classical forms but also trying to make
them consistent with the kind of clean
you know
Roboto design and so I think these are
these three are either new in either
marshmallow or lollipop so then in
addition to you know this kind of large
set of scripts CJK chinese japanese and
korean represent a very large fraction
of the of the users of Android a lot a
lot of the users in the world and so in
lollipop we launched Noto CJK which is a
joint project with Adobe so it's also
out there you know they released it as
source hans hands and that's also an
open source project and it has a tracker
it's very active people you know find
issues and and you know it's it's being
revised and in addition to just the the
fonts that project also kind of brought
with it a high quality renderer for
something called cff compact font format
and this is this is based on the Adobe
code but it's now been open sourced as
part of freetype so you can you can you
know go look at the code use that in
your own projects as well
so notice ejk is is a very ambitious
project that it really is is designed to
be a comprehensive support font to
support all of CJK and that includes the
different the different local forms so
there's a difference between simplified
and traditional Chinese those are
different from Japanese and then there
are some glyphs that appear different in
Korean and it's very important to these
users to see the correct form in their
language if you see it wrong it's it
just it really is a Polish problem so
notice cgk has a unified design there's
like a consistent like there's some
releases that we've done where the
chinese and japanese really don't look
like they're part of the same family of
fonts and in Noto CJK we really have a
unified design but we have the different
variants in the different regions so no
discussion of text is is complete today
without talking about emoji and we
really treat we really treat emoji as
you know a type of text so an app
doesn't have to do anything special an
app doesn't have to say oh you know show
me some color images here or something
like that it just you just represent
text and you ask for the text to be
drawn or in a text view or edited and it
just automatically shows up using this
color font technology which is now
standardized in OpenType 1.7 so and and
there are actually many tools many font
editors actually will create fonts in
this emoji form so if you want to or I
should say in a color font form whether
it's used for emoji or not is is really
up to you and you can you can
incorporate these custom fonts in your
app and get color color representation
of either emoji or text just by dropping
in the font this also supports flags and
key caps it's a it's a more expanded set
of of emoji and one of the new API is I
should say this is a marshmallow API
that a lot of apps you you want to know
what emoji are present because you want
to make a decision do you present this
as a you know as a palette for users to
choose and this has always been a
problem because you know different
phones will have different emoji sets
and you know as we're upgrading it's
it's hard to know is this emoji present
or not or does this flag exist in the
case of the flag emoji and so we've got
this new API that will tell you it's
very fast and we really recommend we
really want you to be using has glyphs
so you know what emoji are on your on
your device what you what you can use so
then I want to talk about some
the typography features we've really
been expanding this you know the goal my
goal certainly is to make Android
typography match what you can do on the
web and match what you can do not just
in print but like really high quality
print and so I'll walk you through some
of the things that we do here I'll just
go through this list and then I'll show
some examples that we we have kerning
and ligatures we've actually had those
since I think jellybean mr2 but now
there's more control so if you want to
turn those on and off there's fine
grained control to do that we have this
font feature settings attribute where
you really can go in and control the
open type features I'll give you several
examples of that and that's using a CSS
compatible syntax so we want to make
this stuff so you know if your designers
are you know used to controlling
typography on the web we want to make
that kind of impedance mismatch as
smooth as possible so so you can just
take that knowledge and apply it to
Android apps and then this is a little
bit more technical thing but we use open
type integrally to give you these
localized forms that there many
languages certainly not just the Chinese
Japanese in Korea and where there's
going to be subtle differences the same
basic script but differences in the way
it's presented and we use open type to
control that and I'll talk a little bit
also about what you want to do in your
app to make that work perfectly so
kerning in ligatures so the FI ligature
is a little controversial in Roboto not
everybody loves this but but it is
definitely a sign of kind of more
sophisticated sophisticated typography
that you don't just put the letters that
in some cases you have these
combinations and you have a specifically
drawn glyph that represents more than
one letter and this is certainly you
know this exists in Roboto and it's a
very important part like especially in
serif fonts you really need those
ligatures for the font to display
correctly so if again as you're using
custom fonts in your app you want those
ligatures and the same is true for
kerning you almost never want to turn
this off the only time you might
want to turn it off is if you've got
some kind of technical alignment where
things need to have the consistent with
you know no matter what the characters
are but in any case as of em with the
font feature setting attribute you can
control these these are actually
implemented as open type features and
with as with any open type feature you
can turn it on or off with font feature
settings and that's a that's actually a
lollipop plus API another kind of great
hidden feature is the use of
proportional and old-style numbers and
these are really important for kind of a
more refined sophisticated typography
that the default numbers are basically
the same size as capitals and they're
all the same width and being the same
width is really important if you've got
some kind of animated display you don't
want it to be juddering back and forth
or if you've got kind of a tabular
presentation of numbers like a
spreadsheet but it's not always the
prettiest display and if you're doing
like running text if you're doing you
know paragraphs of text then
proportional is a maybe a more subtle
change where you just give the one a
little bit narrower so you don't have
all these space around it and then if
you're really trying to do something
that looks more like a book something
that looks more like traditional
typography then you've got these
old-style figures and those are in
Roboto too those are present in the font
and you use the Android font feature
settings to select P non-proportional
numbers or own um old style figures and
again highly recommended if you're
bringing custom fonts into your into
your app that you have the complete
access to all of the open type features
in those fonts and this is again an L
plus feature another another feature
that I think is really powerful tool for
bringing kind of more sophisticated
design to apps is control over letter
spacing so there's a default letter
spacing it's really tuned for legibility
people are getting information on their
phone they need to be able to read it
quickly and that's that
what the default litter spacing is tuned
for but if you have got something that's
kind of larger more of a branding and
less of a kind of a functional element
then spacing it a little tighter might
kind of highlight that and then you can
also use wide spacing as maybe a form of
emphasis or just bringing a little bit
more breadth to your design so you have
your you're no longer stuck with just
the default spacing that's that's set in
your font and again that's an L plus
feature so in marshmallow this is really
one of the things I'm most excited about
that we we really stepped up the
paragraph layout and you know the the
old algorithm kind of used you know you
fill up a line and then when once you
get to the point where the line is full
then you just break at the word boundary
and you keep going but in marshmallow we
have this high quality paragraph layout
mode and it incorporates a couple of
different elements it incorporates
automatic hyphenation and it also
incorporates this concept of whole
paragraph optimization so it kind of
moves pieces around to get like a best
score to get a you know there's a
there's kind of a score that tells you
what is the quality of this layout and
it's really trying to optimize that
across the entire paragraph both of
these algorithms are based on tech which
is a print typography package it has a
very long history and you know high-end
print publishing tools use this same
approach but the parameters you know
like when do you use hyphens hyphens are
a little bit weird people are not used
to seeing them on a mobile device
there's some contexts where they're
where they make a lot of sense like if
you're displaying an e-book for example
and there's some where maybe it makes a
little less sense like UI strings or
maybe chat messages people are not used
to seeing hyphens there so we tuned the
parameters we you know it's it's
heuristics and we kind of chose these so
that a couple of things that people were
noticing that if you
- eight and you break a partial word on
to the last line that is really weird
that's something that people have a
negative reaction to so there's a
parameter in the tuning that kind of
doesn't do that very often but on the
other hand one of the reasons why you
want to do this - ation and want to do
this high-quality paragraph layout is
you want better information density this
is especially important when you have
very narrow settings like an especially
true on very small screens like watch
cases that if you break a word and you
leave a huge amount of empty space
that's waste that's an opportunity that
you could have used that space to
present information so we really look at
this question of would hyphenation bring
you you know n lines down to n minus one
by doing the hyphenation and in that
case we say yes you do want that you
don't want to waste that space you want
more information density and that
increases the chance that you'll get a -
on there so this is this is kind of a
different tuning than you would expect
for something like print typography
which is where there's kind of the most
tradition of doing hyphenation so one of
the other things we looked at is this
question do we want to have like a
opt-in where you know your app says yes
I want high quality mode but maybe it's
considered expensive you know it's too
slow to run or you know we don't want to
always have it but we we tried turning
it on across the entire system as a
default and we really liked what we saw
I mean that you you want a
higher-quality presentation of
paragraphs of course if it is not right
for your app then please turn it off or
control the the tuning parameters but we
also had to do a lot of work on their
performance so you know it's doing a lot
more work it's there's a lot more
sophistication that's going on in there
but overall the amount of time that it
spends drawing text is about the same as
lollipop there's some use cases that are
faster there somewhere - we're you know
like maybe some of the benchmarks where
we've gone backwards but we
really tried to to make that usable for
everybody
so here's a kind of a demo of the kind
of profound difference that you can see
that you really see on the left-hand
side which is the pre M paragraph layout
it you can still get to this by setting
break strategy equals simple in your in
your XML but you see these huge gaps
where you know like the word
conversation it doesn't fit so okay it
just goes to the next line and with the
with the high-quality layout it says
okay we can hyphenate that and we can
actually get this block of text that's
very you know clean lake it really looks
much more like a book and less like kind
of computer text display and on there on
the right hand side you can see it's
actually pretty eager to use hyphens and
that's a control there's a default which
is a little less eager it uses hyphens
when they really improve the density
when you really improve those huge gaps
and then there's this setting of full
hyphenation frequency equals full which
is really appropriate if you are
displaying paragraphs of text if you've
got an app like a ebook reader where
you're really you know displaying
paragraphs then we recommend using full
instead of the default and if you want
to turn hyphenation off you can actually
have you can mix and match you can have
a high quality strategy in terms of the
optimization of where the line breaks go
but just no hyphens and that's another
option in the same kind of you know
increased control and has control over
line breaking we wanted to we were
looking at this particular problem a
very common pattern for UI strings
you've got a string that just doesn't
quite fit into the space into the width
of the set and then you get this word
you know UI strings are often very short
so this happens like quite a lot where
you just have one line but you have like
one or maybe two words that go to the
second line and it just doesn't look
nice it's not a very pleasing visual
presentation of this text so you can
select break strategy equals balanced
and that tries to line it up so that all
of the lines are the same are roughly
the same length you know in a
traditional paragraph you try and get
all of the lines except for the last the
same length but balance just really just
tweaks that one thing and says just make
this whole thing line up this is based
again for designers who are familiar
with web technology this is based on
Adobe's proposal for text wrap balance
that hasn't become a standard I don't
think it's widely shipping yet but you
know again we're trying to make the
design of typography on Android similar
to the design of typography for the web
so I wanted to also I mentioned when I
was talking about the different
languages and the kind of different
things that we do to change the way we
present text that this is really one of
the most important things that apps can
do is to get the locale of the text that
the app is displaying correct because if
it's wrong things will be you'll still
get the text displayed but things will
be degraded they won't be as nice they
won't be as polished as if you set that
locale correctly so there's three
different ways that locale flows into
text in android in android framework
text there's the settings which are
which are system-wide which control a
default locale and of course this is
their fault this is what happens if you
don't do anything and you hope it's
right but unfortunately there are a
bunch of cases mostly when you have
multilingual users we in America there
aren't any but in the rest of the world
there's a lot of people that speak more
than one language and so that so the
language that that that they're viewing
the app in the language that they're
interacting you know they're maybe
looking at user content might not be you
might not match the the system sitting
up so we have a set text locale API
which you can use on a textview and if
you know if you have metadata if your
server knows the language that that text
is then we strongly recommend that you
chat text locale on the text view that
displays that text so that the so that
the locale is correctly identified and
then this may be a little bit more
specialized like for something like a
Translate app where you may have a
single string that contains multiple
languages it might say the translation
of this word into this other language is
some other word and you might have a
language that's just just a span and for
that we have got a locale spam and you
can set that on just just the text in
your app that that represents that span
so what does it look I'll do I mean like
I said it's important to set it but but
what happens like how does that actually
control the way text is displayed and
before jellybean there was no difference
at all like it text just displayed but
in marshmallow there's four different
ways that locale affects the
presentation of text it changes the font
that's chosen and that's especially
important for distinguishing between
traditional and simplified Chinese as
well as Japanese in Korean those are
different fonts that are unified it
affects this local OpenType feature
lookup so that leak there are
differences in Devanagari script between
you know Hindi and Marathi and it makes
sure that you get the correct forms of
those letters things like Persian
numerals and so on or not well Persian
numerals are complicated but the point
is that you if you know the language
then setting it will get the correct
lookups to happen on the font the locale
also affects line breaking there's some
languages where deciding where the
boundaries are between words where you
can break the line is actually kind of a
complex question Thai is the most common
certainly that you'll see where there's
no spaces and so you really in the case
of Thai you need a dictionary you need
to say you know this is the word so that
I know where the boundaries of the words
are and that is completely reliant on
knowing what the language is if you just
put Thai text through but don't identify
that the language is Thai then it gets
confused and you get line breaks in in
potentially very bad places that don't
don't line up with words at all and then
of course lastly
now that we have automatic hyphenation
that knowing which dictionary of
patterns to use depends on the language
and if use and this is like most of the
things that I just talked about you know
are kind of more exotic languages to to
this audience but automatic hyphenation
is important between you know for
example Norwegian and English they're
both in the same script but if you use
the wrong patterns you'll get you'll get
weird - and then there's an you know
like there's this like how do you know
what the what the language is and
fortunately there is an open source
library I mean this is actually mostly
developed by Google but it's out there
the compact language detector library
which is now in its second version as
open source and it's designed to be very
performant very fast it's not a huge
dependency to take on so if you've got
an app where you know you're displaying
messages and you really don't have the
metadata you don't know what where it
came from what that language is but you
want to ensure that it's displayed with
the highest quality and of course that
metadata can be really useful for lots
of other things then then we really do
recommend this this compact language
detector and and that'll you pipe the
output of that intercept look to into
sent text locale and that really
improves the quality of your of your
display so that's that's kind of all of
the prepared topics that I had I want to
open it up to questions I'm happy to
answer any questions you have and please
wait for the mic to come to you
well on the topic of custom fonts so you
can choose custom fonts via like on
simple view such as text view but it's
pretty difficult to do for framework UI
constellations like navigation view or
like toolbar is there a recommended way
by the frameworks team to achieve like
custom fonts globally within your app
yeah that's a good question I we there I
don't think we have a mechanism for like
applying a font you know globally across
the app so unfortunately I think that is
something that you have to do you know
with with code but but that's a that's
something you know that we're interested
in looking at making easier situations
where they want to be exactly this size
possibly because it's aligning with an
image or something like that is there
what is your recommendation for what I
really like to do is have the text
shrink down if it's in a language that
has more text there yeah what is your
recommendation for that that's a very
common request and we do not have
support in the framework for that yet it
is something that we are really looking
at there are a number of open-source
libraries one of the reasons that we
haven't um implemented something like
that we I looked at it and one of the
problems that you get into is that you
get kind of how do you specify what that
behavior should be so you just specify
kind of one point in there where you
want it to be exactly that size but
there's a lot of other use cases where
people are trying to you know because
you're trying to line it up basically
with other other graphic elements
there's a lot of other cases where
people are just mostly concerned about
making it fit so they want kind of
different logic they want something that
says make it a standard size make it 14
SP unless it doesn't fit and then we
excuse me and then we want to have it
shrink down to some other size but we
don't want to have it shrink bound to
you know below like eight because then
it becomes illegible so you get these
cases were like specifying how you want
that behavior to scale is kind of
complicated and that's that's kind of
you know
we when we if and when we do implement
something like that in the framework we
really need to make sure that we get
that we cover the range of behavior in a
way that makes sense until then you know
I'm not gonna recommend any specific
open source library but there's a bunch
of them out there and it's likely that
there's something that just subclasses
you know text view and and and overlays
that behavior that there's light it's
likely that there's something that will
fit what you need
early on I saw mention for CSS Styles
being applied to text is that something
that's done through styles or is it you
through the use of HTML tags okay so I
thought was misleading that it's not CSS
styles in general that we're applying to
text that there are specific attributes
there's specific parameters and that
were in that particular slide I was
talking about font feature settings and
it's like the syntax because you know
specifying all these open type features
is kind of a complex thing it's not just
like a number or something like that and
so we adapted the syntax from CSS it is
compatible with CSS so if you have that
particular feature other features that
we've got like letter spacing the name
of the future the meaning of the feature
we're trying to make it consistent with
CSS but we haven't like implemented a
web browser in android framework you
know text you can use webview but that's
you know there's there is not like a
generic CSS translator it's just these
specific features that are low impedance
or compatible with CSS what is the
performance cost of the high-quality
text layout strategy with hyphenation
for example if you like to want to
actually change the text view contents
so what is that gonna cost you well you
you you know measuring text performance
is really complex I mean the the order
of magnitude is that it's about the same
as simple text in lollipop so you know
it's doing more work but we actual
took a wrench to it and did a lot of
optimizations to make it go faster
there's gonna be some specific cases
that are gonna be a little slower
there's other cases like for if you're
editing a very large buffer that it's
gonna be a lot faster because we really
did a lot of them performance
improvement in that area so ultimately
if you're really concerned about
performance like if you've got if you've
profiled your app and you've said oh my
god I'm spending all of this time doing
the layout of the high quality layout
and if you've decided that the visual
improvement of that is not worth it in
your app then by all means that simple
we have not come across I can't really
think of any apps that I know of either
first party or third party where people
have felt a need to do that but it's
certainly an option and we will continue
to improve the performance there's you
know it's this is a very important area
for us it's got to not jank no
unfortunately a lot of the stuff that
happens in framework text is at such a
low level that you can't really fill it
in with a support library
hi I know better than ask you what are
you guys are going to do in the future
but I wanted to ask a little about I'm
static layout and the new method that
lets you set custom margins per line yes
I know it's not ready to do full
wrapping around a path which is what I
imagined when I first heard about it but
I am wondering what what were you guys
imagining when you out of it is it just
the circular watch space or is there
something else cool oh great no and like
that's a slide that almost happened in
this talk and I wanted to keep it simple
because I wanted to you know talk about
things that you know would would be for
most developers so certainly the
circular watch face so just so maybe I
should just explain that that there's
layers in of the text stack where text
view is the one that most of you
interact with but underneath text view
is static layout and static layout does
a lot of the things around line breaking
and paragraph layout and then below that
is like draw text in the kind of very
low-level api's and instead of a out we
have a new method that lets you kind of
address the shape by controlling indents
on the paragraph and so yes the watch
face was absolutely a motivation for
that we are seeing other applications
people are adopting it in cases where
people are you know doing custom views
rather than just relying on text view
one of the really nice ones is when you
just get to flow around an image where
you're basically doing something like a
you know like a web style float and you
know it is possible to do your own to
kind of roll your own if you've got a
path you know to figure out based on the
knowledge of the line Heights and stuff
like that to figure out what the indents
are I think you will you'll see this
continue to evolve you know clearly
there's you know it makes sense to do a
higher level feature that has you know
kind of easier to use it's not it's not
so low level but unfortunately it is not
there yet
any other questions all right well thank
you so much for coming